peu
pour tous les enfants de par le monde
entier dont les pays sont en guerre plus
souvent qu'en fait je déclare la trêve
pour quelques instants en qualité de
président des moins de 20 ans même si
mon état
la calebasse a deux qui s'appelle
l'amour que j'ai dans le coeur
et même si moh sceptre qu'un petit au
chef respecté le quart maintenance
[Musique]
non
à
[Applaudissements]
pour tous les papas
et toutes les
tous les gêner
on est tous les prix
pour tenir
x qui ne voulait
pour les blancs
les gens le bien les noirs ou l'ouest ou
le sud où l'est ou vial
pour tous les
pour que c'est pas simple
sept locaux
ce sommet
non
[Applaudissements]
écoutez
pardon
le journal
j'espère bien que
avec tout ça
pour ne vous
et que d'un sujet très court en a
en premier
il appelle tous
au journal
ce que je dis
[Musique]
doucet
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
demain
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
après noël 70 nous voyons que non non
rien n'a changé c'est l'histoire d'une
trêve que j'avais demandé si territoire
d'un soleil
j'avais espéré c'est l'histoire d'un
amour que je crois mais vivant si
l'histoire d'un bonjour je m'appelle
enfants que je voulais 13 euros pour
toute la planète je voulais j'espérais
que la paix règne en maître en ce soir
de noël mais tout continuer mais tout à
conquérir tout habitué aux jets
tout d'abord dit
à
les gens chantent y avait tout un
montant bien des gens son visage tout
couvrir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la bbc
non
gfr
plat
mohamed
à
de tara
[Musique]
ah ah
moi je pense
autour de ça moi je pense bon tu
demander pourquoi pas
le temps
je crois
[Musique]
car les cours
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
notre rêve que j'avais demandé si
l'histoire d'un soleil que j'avais
espéré si l'histoire vous que je crois
vivant si l'histoire dans le jour du
mois sauf en juillet
[Musique]
toujours déjà que la paire atrocement
contre youtube
[Musique]
e
à
non
tout est accompli
[Musique]
hahaha
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle avait dix ans
elle était belle elle sourit elle
habitait en face de chez moi
on se voyait
[Musique]
évidemment je lui parlais
notamment
je ne
donne
je sais
moi
un beau jardin
[Musique]
où
mon état
les enfants
il abat
je t'aime
je
il y a
du lycée
[Musique]
oh
il s'appelle
j'appelle
[Musique]
et puis un jour
genou isa
la peine
les partis pour l'étranger
et
mais il va
je t'aime
[Musique]
là
il m
bizarre
[Musique]
là
à
québec
[Musique]
oh
tu seras toujours rien que pour moi
symbole d'amour figure de joie
[Musique]
et tu peux compter sur moi
[Applaudissements]
sur moi
key
[Applaudissements]
où
[Musique]
et sur cet amour
que j'ai pour toi
depuis toujours je joue trois mois
[Musique]
que tu peux compter sur moi
sur moi
en quoi c'est pas très cher
je
[Musique]
mais je sais qu'un jour
un quidam
alé lô
allez
alléluia
oh
témoin
[Applaudissements]
où
mais je sais qu'un jour
tu vieillis voix
et quart
ces moments là
tu pourra compter sur moi
sur moi à
pas
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
à
voilà
[Musique]
ban
vers la colline la balle à bord nous
soleil décline entendu qu'il ya des gars
et puis les filles qui chante toutes les
chansons des chansons pas
non
[Applaudissements]
ou pas
[Musique]
oui
à bord
ils y seront semble d'être sans lui qui
chante euros
ben j des chansons pas
[Musique]
ah ah
les bras
[Applaudissements]
d'abord
[Musique]
je ne serai
là bas
bruxelles
oui
mais chanter jour de la sagesse
déchanter
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et quoi
[Applaudissements]
liberté liberté
[Musique]
eros enfants
ti gais
les deux
il est
il y
tu sais tout là
tous cherchent
[Musique]
liberté
sur la tête
oui
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
du 7
elles m'ont bien
[Musique]
non
tu n'existes août
[Musique]
c'est
dans le coup
[Musique]
oh
liberté
mais oh
sow
à
[Musique]
il voudrait bien tout
retrouver
tu sais
tu n'existes pas
dans l'est
c'est tout
[Musique]
et
l'hiver c'est
[Musique]
et
sont fatigués
il voudrait bien trouver
tu sais que pour ça
tu es
[Musique]
à
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
bah
à
oui non la poussière il est beau il est
sur la terre nous voulons sujet d'une
rémission
[Musique]
il chante
vous travaillez bien me taire son nom
déchets d'une révolution
à
[Musique]
sa jument jeunes ou vieux mas aux
manches et s'est vu l'évolution il mange
quand il a le temps mettant souvent ou
pas souvent rappelez vous son nom c'est
jésus révolution jésus jésus
à
entre les spots jusqu'à vérité
vous l'avez vu vous l'avez
j'en peux plus faire
richebourg menster
[Musique]
je t'ai rien ne savais pas mais c'est ce
qui est bon si jésus
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donne moi ta main et pour la vie
que ge a sonné
sa peau
la joie qui est
[Musique]
les collections
nous irons dans ce
[Musique]
200 m
viens tu dis pas plus
je ne sais pas
[Musique]
l'école est finie
à damas
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
et puis
ma mère
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais bon
elles sont les enfants de la foi
la gauche ou de droite à gauche
[Musique]
ça pousse
coc
il
oui
[Musique]
sans tabac
comment
oui
jeudi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et puis
[Applaudissements]
et il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
à j l
ici
je
[Musique]
quand j'étais un petit garçon je
dédicace
mon programme prend du zich et zune
il porte encore je me suis pas lancé ce
mois-ci
tout est tellement fragile cieux
[Musique]
mais si vous le vine après me remets
que vous soyez si avis contraire
et chantal uche qu'il a finalisé ce mot
prononcé d'un pouce et tomber les
barrières
si vous le nez gentiment chez chimie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand vous nouvelle torpille évoquèrent
provisions
vous allez voir l'inspecteur est dedans
momies qui nous apprendre à vous et
l'habituelle alors la simple plus léché
pour tous plus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à calais
c'est
oui
m
[Musique]